Public Sénat en partenariat avec l'AFP
les échos Radio Classique
[Musique]
présente Jean-Christophe cambadellis le
premier secrétaire du Parti socialiste
et l'invité de l'épreuve de vérité
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous pour
ce rendez-vous de Public Sénat avec la
FP avec Radio Classique et avec les
échos vous répondrez à trois grandes
questions au cours de cette émission oui
d'abord
la crise de la droite est-elle une auine
pour vous vous répondrez à Jean-Francis
pecrè ensuite pourquoi la campagne de
Benoît amont qui est entre 13 et demi VO
voire 16 d'intention de vote selon les
sondages pourquoi la campagne de votre
candidat patine vous le direz à Jérémy
Marot enfin comment résister à la
tentation Macron et oui une tentation
forte chez beaucoup d'élus socialistes
qui vont même désormais jusqu'à lui
offrir leur parrainage question de
Michel zames mais d'abord une question
[Musique]
d'actualité la sofress vient de livré
son baromètre annuel sur le front
national 33 % des Français se disent
désormais en accord avec les idées du FN
même si l'image de ce parti ne
s'améliore pas bien au contraire est-ce
que vous êtes d'abord inquiet ou d'une
certaine manière rassuré par ce sondage
oui on peut être assuré en disant que de
Français sur 3 ne veulent pas du Front
national mais 33 % c'est beaucoup euh
c'est beaucoup euh c'est mon cela
démontre les les les idées du Front
national les positions du Front national
ont pénétré très largement dans la
société française et euh ça crée un
climat propice à sa progression
électorale alors ce qui la freine
apparemment même si elle est toujours
très haut on le sait bien sûr on en
parlera au cours de cette émission c'est
que 58 % des Français et là c'est 11
points de plus qu'en 2012 juge que le FN
est dangereux pour la démocratie donc ça
en fait c'est l'échec de la
dédiabolisation voulu par Marine Le Pen
euh oui mais ceci ne fait pas pour
autant l'équation électorale car si elle
est qualifiée au second tour sielle est
au-dessus de 30 parce que je pense
qu'elle est sous-estimée dans les
sondage et que les autres sont en
dessous de
20 on est dans une équation politique
très très difficile vous pensez que s'il
y a un différentiel de 10 points avec
son suivant elle est sûr d'être élu je
pense que la situation sera difficile
mais d'un certain point de vue le mal le
mal est fait si après il faut que toute
la classe politique quel que soi ses
opinions se met derrière un candidat
pour dire tout sauf Marine Le Pen ser
évidemment mais si elle est qualifié le
mal est fait c'est-à-dire que elle
s'installe définitivement dans le
paysage politique elle sera dans ces
cas-là très haute au second tour et elle
pèsera de tout son poids dans l'élection
législative qu' faut pas oublier d'ors
et déjà vous nous dites quel que soit
l'élu he du second tour un élu
républicain le mal est fait pour lui
bien sûr le mal est fait pour lui
c'estàd qu'il se trouve face à Marine Le
Pen il y aura pas de débat d'ailleurs il
y a pas de débat dans cette élection
présidentielle depuis le début il y a
aucun débat mais là encore plus ça sera
tous sauf Marine Le Pen donc
c c'est presque aussi pire à vous
écouter que si elle était élu non c'est
pas pire que si é élu parce qu'elle
serait à la tête de nos institutions ça
serait dramatique pour la France pour
son im
et puis pour le pays pour sa gestion ti
je n'imagine pas tu Marine Le Pen aurait
à ce moment-là une majorité à
l'Assemblée nationale ça veut dire un
double pouvoir pas soit vous nous dites
que la situation politique sera très
compliquée pour le prochainà toute façon
extr est-ce que vous donc partagez
l'obsession dit-on à l'Élysée de de
François Hollande qui est justement de
rester lui dans la postérité comme le
président qui aura qui aurait accueilli
Marine Le Pen sur le Peron en mai
prochain une obsession je je je je dis
ça depuis des mois et des mois il y a un
risque qu'il faut le le conjurer et que
le seul moyen de conjurer ce ris c'est
de revenir au débat et non pas être dans
la séquence que nous vivons en ce moment
autour des affaires d'accord encore un
mot quand même sur la progression dans
les intentions de vote du Fond national
de Marine Le Pen quelle est la part de
responsabilité de la gauche forcément
vous enemprenez votre part car le le le
le fait que les les couches populaires
comme l'on dit hein les Français qui se
sentent les c'est pour compte et bien se
tourne vers Marine Le Pen c'est aussi le
bilan du quinquena je pense pas que ce
soit le bilan du quinquena c'est un
grand je vais terminer c'est un grand
échec de la part de la gauche
collectivement c'est un échec de ne pas
avoir pu ou su réduire le Front national
parce que je ne crois pas que ce soit le
rôle enfin ce n'est pas la possibilité
de la droite c'est à la gauche de faire
ce travail et n'a pas réussi à le faire
à cause de ses division vision parce que
son projet
progressiste n'est plus efficace dans le
moment présent je je tire un bilan très
négatif de notre notre combat contre le
Front national voilà donc ça ça vous
conduit à de déchirantes révisions donc
si on vous suit je crois que il faudra
s'interroger pourquoi tous les courants
progressistes en Europe et dans le monde
sont dans l'incapacité de faire face au
National populisme à cette nouvelle
donne euh c'est le cas aux États-Unis
mais aussi on le voit en Autriche on
peut on va le voir dans quelques jours
au Pays-Bas où wildilder va arriver très
largement en tête et al il est encore
plus violent lui il a pas de
dédiabolisation il est encore plus
violent tu Marine Le Pen c'est une
nouvelle donne et nous sommes d'un
certain point de vue à gauche désarmés
face à cette nouvelle donne alors
l'information du jour concernant les
sondages encore c'est quand même que
aujourd'hui Emmanuel Macron est au coude
à coude avec Marine Le Pen on en parle
dans la trème partie he dans l'émission
tout de suite la première la suite avec
une autre question que vient poser
Jean-Francis PCR le directeur de la
rédaction de Radio
Classique bonsoir jean-fancis bonsoir
Michel bonsoir Jean-Christophe cambadis
alors est-ce que la crise à droite qui
n'est peut-être pas finie on en parlera
tout à l'heure est-ce que cette crise
c'est une mauvaise nouvelle pour la
démocratie ou est-ce que c'est une obè
pour vous c'est une mauvaise nouvelle
pour la démocratie parce que cette crise
obscurc totalement la
présidentielle on ne peut pas dialoguer
échanger proposer on est toujours ramené
la preuve
à Monsieur Fillon ses affaires Marine Le
Pen ses affaires et en pas affecté oui
mais mais mais on nous interroge un peu
moins d'ailleurs mais on nous interroge
sur ces questionsl donc le temps que
l'on passe à répondre à stigmatiser à
dire que c'est pas bien il faut changer
les choses ou à invectiver la droite sur
ce sujet on ne le passe pas développer
nos propres projets dans son édition de
ce soir qui sera en kiosque demain le
Canard Enchaîné révèle que François
Fillon aurait bénéficié en 2013 d'un prê
sans intérêt de Marc l'adrs de
lâchearrière qui n'aurait pas été
déclaré à la Haute autorité pour la
transparence de la vie publique est-ce
que vous pensez que c'est une nouvelle
affaire Fillon qui est en train de
démarrer est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est un nouveau scandale bah évidemment
on est obligé de le faire de déclarer si
vous mentez à la Haute Autorité comment
on peut vous faire confiance après alors
j'entends que ce l'avocat de Monsieur
Fillon dit mais il a déclaré
spontanément au au aux policiers quand
sont venus l'interroger bon d'accord je
veux bien que se rendant compte que ceci
allait être découvert il est dit tiens
au fait j'ai fait un emprunt mais vous
voyez bien que tout ça c'est franchement
voilà ce que vous voulez que je vous
dise moi les bras m tombe vous voyez
bien le soupçon qu'il y a derrière cette
affaire ce ce prêt c'est un soupçon de
de favoritisme ou de trafic d'influence
en lien avec la Légion d'honneur qui
aurait été accordée à Marc l'ADR de
lâcharrière sur l'intervention de
François Fillon est-ce que c'est quelque
chose qui vous qui vous paraît euh non
je je veux pas aller dans ce sens c'est
c'est votre rôle de de journaliste de de
s'interroger ou d'interroger mais moi je
veux pas alimenter cela car pour
l'instant personne n'a de preuve euh et
je moi je crois très fortement à la
présemption d'innocence mais il y a pas
besoin d'aller à la
contrepartie pour dire que ceci n'a pas
été déclaré voilà point donc là il y a
une faute faute est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment que dans cette campagne
présidentielle la droite a au fond perdu
le combat moral qui était le sien
c'était le combat de François Fillon
contre François Hollande c'était le
combat aussi de la stature
présidentielle d'une certaine idée de la
fonction ah je crois que François Philon
l' l'a compris et que il a voulu que
l'attitude euh prenne le pas sur les
turpitudes h que l'attitude soit celui
de l'homme qui fait face aux événements
et que ceci permettent de mettre de côté
les turpitudes mais enfin les turpitudes
sont là et c'est un problème qui est
posé à l'ensemble de la société
politique française et qui démontre
quand même euh une très grande crise
dans laquelle nous sommes comment est-ce
que vous jugez François Fillon
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'il vous inspire
et qu'est-ce que vous inspirent les
images de ce rassemblement dimanche a
Trocadero que certains observateurs
certains observateurs ont qualifié de
trumpien presque populiste bah au point
de départ quand ceci a été lancé c'était
la guerre des pouvoirs c'est-à-dire le
pouvoir politique contre le pouvoir
judiciaire c'était pas ça à l'arrivée à
l'arrivée ça a été un peu changé parce
que quand on est candidat à l'élection
présidentielle c'est difficile d'être
dans cette guerre de pouvoir mais ça
indique quelque chose c'est que la
droite elle existe en
France à tous ceux qui pensaient qu'elle
avait disparu elle existe elle elle elle
a une force elle a une représentation et
et et que cette droite là elle ne veut
pas de la gauche s toutes ses formes h
mais allons plus loin parce que si elle
ne veut pas de la gauche sur toutes ses
formes moi je suis très intiet d'un
deuxème tour
entre Marine Le Pen et par exemple
Emmanuel Macron ou benoî mon je ne sais
pas ce que va faire la droite et vous
attendez quoi des éclaircissements des
précisions du candidat Fillon ex lu dem
lui demandez quoi mais je lui demande
par exemple de nous dire en cas
d'élimination si il appellerait à voter
pour un candidat républicain je je veux
pas personnifier est-ce qu'il le ferait
je n'en suis pas certain vous avez un
doute aujourd'hui vous avez j'ai j'ai un
doute parce que cette base elle est
chauffée à blanc elle est là présente en
disant on ne va pas nous voler la
victoire donc s'il n'est pas au second
tour sa victoire aura été volé c'est
quoi son réflexe mais c'est pour ça que
je dis on se rend pas compte on dit W de
toute façon il y a le plafond de verre
et cetera pour Marine Le Pen mais on se
rend pas compte de ce que il est en
train de s'installer vous n'êtes pas sûr
que là ce soir si François Fillon est
éliminé du 2è tour il appellera à voter
Emmanuel Macron ou Benoît amont Benoît
amont
non je suis pas sûr mais le Lini c'est
c'est quand même une théorie qui existe
pour l'élection présidentielle c'est à
voir c'est à voir et d'abord le le
candidat puis après l'électorat comment
il va-t-il se comporter il avait eu
cette phrase lui-même en fait d'ailleurs
je préférais le candidat le moins
sectaire entre un candidat PS et un
candidat FN le sur la personnalité de
François Fillon est-ce que trouvez ou
sur l'image que vous avez de lui
aujourd'hui voilà
c'est un c'est un homme qui euh est
sûrement combatif euh mais est-ce un bon
combat il a quelques
qualités je connais pas au point de dire
s'il a des qualités ou sil a des défauts
euh je pense que oui il a des des des
des qualités il présente la dimension
d'un homme d'État mais à un moment donné
on est un peu
perplexe dans entre cet homme qui été
Premier ministre qui a dû incarner
l'intérêt général et et qui a pris
tellement de liberté avec certain
intérêt général alors c'est qui
Fillon celui qui fait ce prêt ou celui
qui diriger la France comme premier
ministre à un moment donné on ne sait
plus et c'est qui je nen sais rien pour
vous qu'il sera plus inapte que les
autres élus éventuels puisque vous nous
avez dit que ce serait de toute façon
très difficile pour le prochain
président à gouverner est-ce qu'il sera
selon vous inapte notamment en raison de
ce que vous dites mais mais regardez si
euh inapte ou empêché oui mais si s'il
l'emportait admettons il se retrouverait
dans une situation
d'emblé où les médias son opposition
politique serait constamment en train de
lui rappeler le prê de machin le la
position de truc vous réserjà
comm vous imaginez mais ce n'est pas une
menace c'est une réalité vous pourriez
pas même pas commencer un interview du
président de la République si c'était
Fillon sans lui dire mais au fait que
fait madame Fillon elle travaille ou
elle travaille pas bon sans
dire monsieur vous avez vous avez
décerné les légions d'honneur est-ce que
il n'y aurait pas des amis à vous donc
on voit que il serait un président
d'emblé c'est un président faible quel
que soit son caractère pour des raisons
politique et de psychologie euh sociale
euh bon c'est c'est ça pose quand même
un problème euh euh pour le pays hein hm
hm en tous les cas Alain Jupé a eu des
mots très dures hier en confirmant qu'il
ne sera pas le plan B on l'écoute et
vous réagissez
gachi au lendemain de notre primaire
dont le résultat a été incontestable et
incontesté François Fillon à qui j'avais
immédiatement et loyalement apporté mon
soutien avait un boulevard devant lui le
déclenchement des investigations de la
justice à son encontre et son système de
défense fondé sur la dénonciation d'un
prétendu complot et d'une volonté
d'assassinat politique l'ont conduit
dans une impasse le noyau des militants
et sympathisants LR s'est
radicalisé un certain nombre de gens à
gauche ont au fond saluez cette
intervention d'Alain Jupé il dit que
c'était l'intervention d'un homme d'État
est-ce que vous partagez cette
impression je pense que c'est
l'invention d'un homme d'État etcuit
euhuit et conduit par qui bah par le
scrutin de la primaire il y avait quand
même quelques ressentiments et et
conduit dans la possibilité de revenir
revenir ouais donc il y avait certes de
la prestance le choix des mots
était très important c'était une
intervention scalpelle si je puis dire
mais enfin on sentait derrière un peu de
ressentiment alors que pour la deuxième
fois il aurait pu
h et donc il a fois
stigmatisé monsieur Fillon qui ne
s'était pas mis sur le côté et Nicolas
Sarkozi qui n'avait peut-être pas tout
fait pour qu'il se mette de côté dans
les derniers jours précisément puisque
que vous en parler vous en parle
l'ancien chef de l'État Nicolas Sarkozy
a beaucoup manœuvré œuvré dans les
coulisses pour bloquer a-on dit le
retour de Alain Jupé qu'est-ce que ça
vous inspire de voir un ancien chef
d'État continuer de se mêl comme ça des
manœuvres de son parti alors qu'il a dit
lui-même qu'il prenait sa retraite de
voilà voilà vous faites la la réponse à
la question c'est-à-dire que il ne
changera jamais Nicolas Sarkozi jamais
j'avais dit j'étais un des seuls le soir
de sa
déclaration attendez 3 mois il sera de
nouveau là car il était clair que malgré
belle déclaration d'ailleurs très à la
fois émouvante et toujours beau les
déclarations de départ le du départou
mais le c'était en fa départ il est il
est déjà de retour avec cette
dimension cachée hein parce que on le
voit jamais il reçoit dans ses bureaux
il téléphone on fait savoir qu'il
téléphone et cetera un peu comme s'il
voulait être toujours
le j'allais dire le parrain c'est
peut-être beaucoup exagéré poser la
questionexpression revient beaucoup dans
la presse mais
B je pas être blessant mais celui qui
est le grand ordonnateur de la droite
mais peêtre luiême un jour si vouses
c'est plus un interview c'est moi qui
vous intervie JEE la question
alors oui oui il a pas renoncé à jouer
un rôle on va dire dans les années qui
viennent ah bon bien sûr c'est-à-dire
quel rôle bah je sais pas peut-être
celui qui va aider à la recomposition de
la droite si celle-ci est à terre ou
participer du débat si celle-ci prés
devant les électeurs on pas fini avec
fini on pas fini de 2 jours après le
Trocadero il semble que la droite essaie
quand même de se remettre en ordre de
bataille que même des jupéistes essaient
maintenant de rejoindre les rangs de
François Fillon après les avoir quitté
est-ce que pour vous la droite est-ce
qu'elle redevient une menace elle n'a
jamais cessé de l'être euh car là on
avait vu des électeurs se dérober alors
dans les sondages parce que maintenant
on fait la politique qui avait qui à
partir des sondages mais il était pas
normal tu des électeur de droite et éta
choqué parce que par les révélations qui
ont été faites autour de Monsieur Fillon
alors maintenant est-ce qu'ils vont
revenir nous savons rien est-ce qu'ils
estiment que c'est définitivement
terminé nous en savons rien est-ce que
Monsieur Fillon va accentuer sa
radicalisation contre les pouvoirs
contre les élites va trumpiser ce sa
campagne nous en savons rien donc c'est
un peu Trô pour pour le dire qu'est-ce
que va demander l'UDI en contrepartie
mais vous voyez bien que ce paysage
où un jour on dit c'est fini je m'en
vais je peux plus être dans la campagne
et puis le lendemain on revient on
s'assoit à la bonne table monsieur
Larcher j'ai trouvé ça un franchement
extraordinaire devant le le le le siège
de campagne annonçant que le Bureau
politique pas le pas le comité politique
il a dit le Bureau politique le Bureau
politique avait décidé à l'unanimité
avec des gens qui avaient condamné le
candidat bon tout ça c'est terrible pour
la démocratie merci Jean-Francis la
deuxème partie de l'épreuve de vérité
maintenant avec Jérémy Marot de l'Agence
France press qui vient vous poser sa
question l'épreuve de vérité avec
lafp bonsoir Jérémy bonsoir bonsoir
Monsieur cambadellis alors on est à 40
jours après 41 jours après la
désignation de de benoîtont dans la
primaire on est à 47 jours du premier
tour de l'élection présidentielle et
pourtant la campagne de votre candidat a
du mal à décoller alors comment vous
l'expliquez on a vu qu'il y avait des
des sondages qui montraient que benoî
monont plafonnait 13 14 % quel est votre
diagnostique et quel remède vous voulez
apporter au chevet de votre candidat
écoutez nous sommes dans la plaine nous
allons aborder les premiers lacés de
l'Alpe duise donc vous savez tous si
vous êtes des amateurs du Tour de France
que ce n'est pas dans la plaine que l'on
fait le trou mais dans les montées il y
a un certain nombre
d'éléments devant nous je pense tout
simplement que Benoît amont est passé de
6 % dans les sondages à 16 % pour 13 %
en on verra entre les deux qu'il a fait
un saut considérable qu'il a dû le
stabiliser et que maintenant il rentre
dans le cœur de sa campagne mais c'est
difficile c'est difficile pourquoi parce
qu'il a fait des erreurs non c'est pas
parce qu'il a fait des erreurs c'est
difficile parce que alors là on va
passer au football il peut pas installer
il ne peut pas installer son son jeu il
ne peut pas installer son jeu à chaque
fois qu'il fait une proposition il
discute il propose et ben on est dans
les affaires donc c'est difficile de
l'entendre et c'est une question qui est
posée d'ailleurs à Jean-Luc
Mélenchon aussi ou même mais mais si
c'est difficile de l'entendre
aujourd'hui il y a des candidats qui ne
disent strictement rien hein dans le
même temps Emmanuel Macron a pu
présenter son programme dans le même
temps Emmanuel Macron a pu présenter son
programme présenter le chiffrage de son
programme lui il a été audible sur ses
propositions mais il va le faire avec un
petit livre manifeste dans les jours qui
viennent et peut-être que c'est bien vu
parce que Emmanuel Macron a présenté son
programme dans un moment de paroxismique
de polémique autour de Fillon ça pas été
tellement vu mais peut-être qu'il
voulait pas que ça soit trop vu euh et
là Benoît amont va pouvoir le faire au
vu et au su de tout le monde donc il est
encore temps pour vous de revenir sur le
fond de reparler des des des
problématiques qui finalement vont
intéresser les Français oui je pense je
pense que c'est parce que les Français
commencent à être exaspérés du fait
qu'on ne parle pas d'eux et qu'on ne
parle pas de la France donc le candidat
qui va commencer à en parler
sérieusement va à à mon avis engranger
des points alors l'autre question c'est
est-ce que tout le monde est en ordre de
marche derrière le candidat socialiste
est-ce Queau sein de la famille
socialist tout le monde est est derrière
lui bah non il y a
des contestations des interrogations des
propositions des inflexions il y a comme
toujours chez les socialistes le fait
qu'on veut l'emporter et queon est
nombreux à à suggérer bon moi je dis à
tout le monde garder C
que la campagne est présidentielle
évidemment elle est à la fois
présidentielle et législative on rien
oublier dans notre
dispositif et que ce n'est pas encore
terminé et donc il faut se concentrer
faire des propositions au candidat ça me
semble utile chercher à le déstabiliser
ça me semble inutile qui qui cherche à
le déstabiliser
de personne à cette étape pour personne
à cette étape mais je j'entends bien le
brouara auut déstabilisé ce sont de
nombreux élus du parti socialiste par la
la campagne qu'il a mené et par les les
les choix radicaux et on entend par
exemple un je voyais monsieur canner le
ministre des Sports dire mais quand
est-ce qu'on va avoir des messages
d'amour de notre candidat bon ça on peut
en donner formule une formule ça coû
chessage d'amour mais bon je je veux
dire il est évident je crois que le
candidat l'a l'a parfaitement compris
que il faut maintenant être le candidat
tout du moins c'est mon souhait que
Benoît am mon soit le candidat de toutes
les gauches et de tous les écologistes
c'est un moment important il doit être
en capacité de rassembler toutes les
gauches et tous les écologies je reviens
sur ces message d'amour il doit tendre
davantage la main à une certaine partie
de de de sa famille il doit tendre la
main à tout le monde il tendre la main
ça veut dire quoi il faut qu'il
rassemble faut qu' faut qu'il ouvre les
bras plutôt qui tend la main euh il a
fixé un cap ce cap a été adoubé par la
primaire maintenant il faut que tout le
monde soit rassemblé c'est c'est un ve
pieux pour l'instant là il faut
qu'est-ce qu'il doit faire non c'est pas
un V pieux il a il a il a rassemblé dans
son équipe de campagne il a ouvert à des
responsables qui n'étaient pas avec lui
dans la primaire mais il faut que il
parle à tout le monde c'est très très
important il y avait juste avant sur ce
plateau Christophe car qui lui par
exemple membre du Parti socialiste lui
il a fait le choix d'aller de le de de
le raller à votre cause oui mais donc
lui il a fait un choix qui est d'aller
vers Emmanuel Macron je pense qu'il a
tort tout simplement alors c'est un
parmi d'autres hein parce que regardez
il y a Claude Bartelone aussi le
président de l'Assemblée qui dit lui
hésiter entre Emmanuel Macron et Benoît
Hamont notamment en raison de sa vision
du du travail et donc ça nous amène à la
question du revenu universel aujourd'hui
à Marseille votre candidat a dit que
tout allait bien pour lui et mais quand
même il a annoncé une inflexion de son
projet phare peut-être qu'il lui a
d'ailleurs permis de remporter la
primaire on regarde Benoît amont tout va
bien tout va bien tout va bien inquier
ou en colère ou ça vous agace pas ni
inquiet ni en colère là si je devais
m'inquiéter être en colère pour pour ça
je vous savez non non moi tout va bien
jeis en bonne santéog le revenu
universel d'existance ça rapporte aussi
de l'argent et les coûts qui seront ceux
de la mesure que je République dans les
2 48h
72h seront de nature à bah à rassurer
ceux qui imaginer qu'on allait ruiner
l'état alors cette mesure de de revenu
universel c'était le gros point fort de
Benoît mon durant la la primaire de la
gauche on en a énormément parlé ça
focalisé la tenension durant la durant
cette primaire et là on a l'impression
que c'est plus une épine dans le pied
qui se retrouve à amender rétropédaler
est-ce qu'il doit se recentrer amender
ce projet de revenu universel je pense
que c'est une très bonne idée parce
qu'il vient de remettre le sujet à
l'ordre du jour ça a été son point fort
euh et au fur à mesure ce point c'est
dissou dans les affaires et dans tout ça
et en le précisant il le remet à l'ordre
du jour donc vous allez voir dans la
proportion attendez là on est parti sur
400 milliards de dépenses là on arrive à
quelques dizain précise donc on en
rediscute donc il se remet au centre du
débat politique puisque vous disiez
qu'il ne faisait pas campagne donc là il
va se remettre au centre d'ailleurs vous
avez commencé vous faites des plateaux
sur le sujet toutes les médias vont en
faire dans 2 jours je sais pas quoi dans
48 he il va préciser les choses et donc
il va se réinsérer dans euh la campagne
présidentielle de son point de vue c'est
une bonne chose et en plus il va le
faire en cherchant de la crédibilité qui
est au fond la question qui lui est
posée par un certain nombre de
dirigeants politiques et donc il fait
coup double il faut qu'il se recentre
davantage sur d'autres éléments de de
son programme et quitte à peut-être
venir davantage se déporter sur l'ail
droite et tendre la main aux électeurs
tentés par Emmanuel Macron je crois pas
il faut faire en terme d'elle droite
d'elle gauche et cetera parce qu'à la
fin on a le tourni mais il faut parler à
tout le monde et une manière de parler à
tout le monde c'est par exemple de
préciser son projet européen moi lors de
son discours d'investiture j'ai été très
intéressé par ce son engagement européen
c'est assez peu souligné et ses
propositions pour l'Europe un moment où
le président de la République
travaille dans le sommet de Versailles
avec Madame Merkel monsieur Haroy le
président du Conseil italien pour faire
des propositions pour relancer l'Europe
c'est une séquence dans laquelle il
devrait à mon avis s'exprimer ce qui
montrerait tout à la fois son intérêt
pour l' pour l'Europe sa dimension de
Capac capité d'incarnation et puis
parlerait vraisemblablement à beaucoup
de socialistes qui sont très
proeopéens on a vu que Benoît monont
était à Marseille aujourd'hui demain ce
sera Jean-Luc Mélenchon à Marseille ils
se suivent il se marquent un petit peu à
la culotte est-ce que c'est de là
incarne des positions irréconciliables à
gauche elles sont là les gauches
irréconciliables ou encore on peut
espérer un accord au bout du chemin moi
je suis assez sévère avec Jean-Luc
Mélenchon car si il avait fait un accord
avec Benoît amont aujourd'hui la gauche
serait en tête dans les sondages donc
évidemment il a le droit de de se
maintenir
mais il n'a pas de raison de le faire
moi je ne suis pas d'accord avec Benoît
monont par exemple sur la loi travail
mais lui et Mélenchon ils sont d'accord
alors pourquoi prendre le risque de
faire perdre cette gauche là par exemple
porte un très une très grande
responsabilité d'autant que en face il y
a une droite qui est extrêmement dure et
puis il y a une extrême droite possible
donc moi je suis très sévère avec lui
sur ce sujet est-ce que est-ce que
Benoît amont a perdu trop de temps à
courir après Jean-Luc Mélenchon on l'a
vu il y a quelques semaines là il
cherchait un accord qui semblait
impossible à atteindre étant entendu que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon était farouchement
déterminé à être candidatil perd moi je
dit assez tôt que jel mlch
ne viendrait pas je ne suis pas
favorable à l'accord avec Jean-Luc
Mélenchon loin de là mais je pense que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon vu ses positions et
Benoît amont les siennes il n'était pas
impossible qu'il se retrouve après
est-ce qu'il a passé trop de temps il le
dit lui-même que il a donné l'impression
de passer du temps même s'il faisait
campagne dans ses débats mais enfin au
passage il a quand même réussi cet
élément historique depuis 1974 de
rassembler tous les écologistes derrière
lui ceux qui étaient dans le
gouvernement et ceux qui étaient contre
le gouvernement donc il faut pas non
plus euh lui reprocher euh les démarches
qui ont été euh les siennes mais à
l'évidence il faut aujourd'hui aller
chercher euh un électorat euh qui est
possible de le ramener à la candidature
euh de Benoît abon qui est un électorat
un peu troublé du tournant centre- droit
euh de Monsieur Macron h cet accord avec
les écologiste justement que vous
évoquez il a pu faire grincer des dents
au sein même de la famille socialiste on
a vu qu'il y avait beaucoup de
circonscription qui était dévolu au
candidat écologiste est-ce que selon
vous c'est un bon accord est-ce que vous
l'approuvez est-ce qu'il était ratifié
également au sein des instances vous
savez moi je suis pragmatique à partir
du moment où il conduit au retrait du
candidat écologiste ça clarifie la
situation et ça permet d'avancer la
seule chose que j'ai posé et que je
continuerai à poser c'est la réciprocité
c'est-à-dire que les écologistes ne
peuvent pas tout à la fois avoir le
soutien du parti socialiste et faire des
accords avec le Parti communiste et le
Front de gauche contre les socialistes
ça ça n'a pas ça n'a pas de s donc
modulo
euh cette précision
euh département par département par
exemple je vois que madame Cécile Duflot
soutient Caroline DEAS contre
myriamcomery si elle veut notre soutien
dans le 11e arrondissement la 6e
circonscription bah elle peut pas
soutenir quelqu'un qui combat un
socialiste faut qu'elle fasse son choix
si elle préfère être en primaire contre
les socialistes elle le dit mais on peut
pas avoir le beurre et l'argent du
beurre encore hein non non mais ça c'est
c'est c'est juste des des des des des
affinements dans le débat mais vous avez
parlé des écologiste que benoî réussi à
à réunir derrière lui il y a quand même
François du rugi qui lui a participé à
la primaire et qui va maintenant du côté
de Macron est-ce que vous le juger
sévèrement écoutez à partir du moment on
a signé un engagement euhon le respecte
hein moi je sais pas après on peut faire
des leçons de morale à toute la classe
politique mais enfin quand vous avez
d' signé l'ude PRG c'est en bonne voie
aussi ils ont ils attendent ils reportte
le leur soutien ben oui je ils ont ils
ont signé mais ce n'est pas sylvia Pinel
qui est dans comité de campagne mais le
Parti radical qui
s'interroge veut lui aussi des pruve
d'amour est-ce que vous regrettez que
François Hollande ne se soit pas
présenté ou n pas été en cap ité de se
présenter à cette élection à une
nouvelle candidature tout à fait je l'ai
toujours dit aujourd'hui plus plus qu'il
y a quelques jours quelques semaines
aujourd'hui plus qu' hier et cetera
puisqueil y a un candidat et moi je veux
pas non apparaître comme le remettant en
cause
j'ai militer je crois que ça s'est vu
pour des primaires permettant au
président de la République de concourir
c'était à faire si çait à faire c'est
c'est à lui de le dire l'histoire dira
pourquoi HM son nombre plan en tout cas
sur cette primaire elle a été taillée
pour lui
maintenant la primaire elle est loin
derrière nous hein maintenant on est
dans la campagne h merci Jérémy allez
dernière partie de l'épreuve de vérité
et c'est maintenant Michel zames de
Public Sénat qui nous
[Musique]
rejoint bonsoir Michell bonsoir Michel
bonsoir Monsieur Kamba d'élice bonsoir
moi je voudrais savoir tout simplement
si euh vous allez résister à la
tentation d'Emmanuel Macron par qu'ils
sont de plus en plus nombreux hein et
mais ils ont plutôt envie d'y aller qui
certains de vos amis du Parti socialiste
et d'autres des ministres même moi je
dis à tout le monde gardez votre sang
froid l'élection qui vous écoute gardez
votre sang froid ou B ça on verra je dis
gardez votre sang
frroid
aujourd'hui nous avons une primaire qui
a désigné un
candidat je suppose qu' s un autre il
seoserait pas cette question
euh et je pense
que il faut
euh prendre le temps que la campagne
s'installe les chiffres parlent
peut-être de même parce que la politique
c'est aussi de l'arithmétique il a un
sondage ailable qui est paru ce soir au
premier tour Emmanuel Macron talonne
vraiment Marine Le Pen 26 pour Marine Le
Pen 25 et demi pour Emmanuel Macron
est-ce que c'est pas lui qui est devenu
le vote utile pour barrer la route au
Front national comme vous vous appelz de
vos vœux et là c'est ce C sondeurs qui
ont annoncé pendant toute la campagne de
la droite que Jupé allait gagner pendant
toute la campagne de la gauche que
Montebourg était en tête c'est de cela
vous nous parlez hein bon ben je les
crois pas il y a l'OP également qui le
dit ce so ils disent pas tout à fait la
même chose hein mais je je je pense
que j'ai un reproche à faire au sondeur
c'est qu'ils tirent leur
sondage pour faire une reprise dans les
trois points qui ils ont de de
possibilités il tir vers le haut pour
pour que ça permette de dire bah voilà
et ça permet de faire des plateaux si
vous entends bien vous êtes en train de
dire qu'Emmanuel Macron c'est l'homme
des sondeurs non je dis pas ça je dis
les les sondeurs sont suffisamment
habiles pour créer des des des fauses
nouvelles nouvell pour créer des
nouvelles et donc des des des polémiques
SAG les surs ce sont des auteurs de fake
news c'est ça que vous nous dites il
joue sur les marches d'erreur pour
oui s de ça ou les fake news de de laab
et des autres instituts mais donc si je
vous entends bien Emmanuel Macron ne
serait pas le candidat qui pourrait
faire barrage au Front national parce
que c'est ça la vraie question parler
des Lab je prends écoutez je prends les
problèmes les uns après les autres ok
d'abord qui doit être au second tour
est-ce que c'est notre candidat ou un
autre candidat à priori c'est plutôt
notre candidat de deuxèement peut-il
notre candidat faire face à Marine Le
Pen s'il est au second tour sera-t-elle
au second tour on n sait strictement
rien parce qu'on on a on a on a installé
le fait qu'elle était obligatoirement au
second tour ça va peut-être la grande
les sondeurs ça peut être la grande
information au soir des élections la
grande nouvelle elle y est pas bon et
donc on aura construit tout un système
par rapport à ça j'ai pendance à penser
qu'elle y sera mais bon c'est quand même
un un élément à avoir en tête après
est-ce que euh on peut créer un combat
une dynamique par rapport euh à Marine
Le Pen moi j'ai tendance à penser que
euh pour battre Marine Le Pen il faut un
un une dynamique populaire
euh et que l'on ne peut pas euh la
laabattre simplement par le people par
une personnalité il faut un ensemble et
les propositions qui mobilisent le
peuple parce que j'ai j'ai peur que tout
le monde ne se retrouve pas sinon donc
Emmanuel Macron n'est pas cet ensemble
n'est pas cet ensemble à cette étape
pour l'instant on n pas encore engagé la
totalité du débat est-ce qu'il vous
arrive d'avoir des hésitations moi je
n'hésite pas généralement en politique
vousz où je peux en venir ais pas c'est
pas trop compliqué c'est pas compliqué
non bon pour ceux qui qui ont peut-être
pas suivi he Claude Bartolone qui est
quand même le président de l'Assemblée
nationale dit aujourd'hui hésiter entre
Benoît amamont et Emmanuel Macron vous
l'avez compris vous avez eu un haut cœur
en lisant ça qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
j'ai pas eu un haur
je je sais que Claude
Bartelone oui oui c'est un ami mais
Claude Bartelone est arabusté si je puis
dire par la montée du Front national on
revient dont on parlait à l'ANT donc et
lui s'il hésite c'est pas qu' il na pas
dit ce soir dans le monde que il
choisissait Emmanuel Macron il regarde
il dit d'ailleurs dans le même interview
mais on n pas titré ça là-dessus que
évidemment Benoît amont est légitime
puisqu'il a gagné la
primaire mais bon
enfe mais quel message le message du
président de l'Assemblée nationale
patron des députés socialistes également
qui dit aujourd'hui qu'il hésite c'est
un message envoyé c'est le patron de
l'assembléeé nationale qui ne se
représente pas donc il a une certaine
liberté d'accord donc il dit moi je suis
pas dans les instances je suis candidat
à rien pour la suite et je dis mais bon
alors lequel des
deux peut être le plus efficace déjà on
a éliminé la droite c'est bien le Tiel
des deux peut être le plus plus efficace
pour combattre le Front national je
préférais qu'il disent Benoît amont
évidemment puisque c'est le candidat qui
est sorti de la primaire mais moi je
comprends aussi euh ses hésitations ses
réflexions ses suputations mais je dis
que ce n'est pas en en en tournant
autour de cela que l'on fera la campagne
de Benoît amont parce que si on tourne
autour de si on tourne si on fait ça on
l'affaiblit non je dis pas ça il contre
son camp euh B n'a jamais tiré contre
son C mais il dit tout haut à l'occasion
d'un interview plutôt sur l'Assemblée
nationale bon ben en ce momentur balance
ou non il'inog il est pas il y a des
secrétaires d'État qui sont prononcés
encore ce matin sur une radio il y a
même des ministres Juliette Méadel
s'interroge également sur la campagne de
beno amamont qui dit aussi s'interroger
sur l'avenir il y a des ministres aussi
qui pourraient rejoindre Emmanuel Macron
c'est la fuite c'est une sorte de fuite
en avant écoutez je crois que ce n'est
pas un bon calcul parce que pour moi euh
le Parti socialiste ne doit être ni le
partenaire junior de Macron ni le
partenaire junior de Mélenchon le Parti
socialiste doit être incontournable dans
la victoire comme dans la défaite et il
ne faut pas penser court terme il faut
s'interroger évidemment sur comment
faire pour combattre le Front National
et le battre euh lors des élections
présidentielles p pense à leur carrière
à leur avenir non c'est pas ça c'est
court terme c'est-à-dire bon là il y a
il y a le problème du front
nationalurence législativ aussi on
parler mais évidemment je je je dis je
dis si on casse le Parti socialiste il
faut pas penser que le Parti socialiste
sera en forme
législative donc il faut avoir du sang
froid et de la responsabilité parce que
j'estime que le Parti socialiste va être
totalement nécessaire dans la période
qui s'ouvre de la présidentielle et
au-delà totalement nécessaire à notre
démocratie et il vaut mieux qu'il soit
incontournable dans la victoire et dans
la défait que casser en plusieurs
morceaux et donc incapable de per sur
les événements et ce ne sont pas des
hommes qui vont puser sur les événements
c'est le président évidemment mais la
majorité parlementaire vous parlez de
parti politique on sent quand même qu'il
y a aujourd'hui une droite fracturée une
gauche pas loin non plus vous qui avez
théorisé sur les le tripartisme et
cetera
onulp c'est multipartisme l'explosion du
tripartisme oui oui oui mais évidemment
mais mais à partir du moment vous aviez
le tripartisme et que le bipartisme a
explosé il n'était pas anormal que on
arrive à les miettement alors vous avez
parlé des législatifes vous avez adressé
des courriers à des élus qui
parineraient ou qui parinent Emmanuel
Macron C courriers sont arrivés vous
avvez peut-être même eu des réponses je
viens de recevoir par mail la réponse de
François patria à l'un des courriers que
vous lui avez adressé vous dites
simplement que ils ne pourront plus se
réclamer du PS qu'est-ce que vous leur
dites exactement alors donc dans ce
courrier
vous en avez adressé combien d' d'abord
bah ceux qui ont signé combien euh les
les parlementairesé une petite dizaine
une dizaine le
parinage Emmanuel Macron ce que je leur
dis c'est qu' connaissent la plupart
d'entre eux ce sont des camarades qui
connaissent les statuts du parti
socialiste ils sont pas ignorants donc
je leur dis bah voilà tu connais les
statuts tu t'es mis dans la
situation deevenir à nos statuts donc tu
peux plus représent ésent le Parti
socialiste et du coup est-ce que c'est
est-ce que c'est une sanction pour vous
ce que à ne plus représenter le Parti
socialiste c'est une sanction une s il a
plus sévère hein quand même hein euh bah
pour ceux qui sont candidats au
législatif c'est assez compliqué moi je
me rappelle qu'il y a peu de temps vous
parliez même d'exclure h non j'ai jamais
dit l'exclure vous savez je fais très
attention à ce que je dis dans ce
domaine vous savez je n'ai pas exclu les
frondeurs qui était favorable au dépôt
d'une motion de censure contre leur
propre gouvernement et qui partait
participer à des manifestations
manifestations excusez-moi assez
violentes contre le gouvernement j'ai
dit que la question de leur appartenance
au groupe socialiste au Parti socialiste
serait posé si cette motion était
déposée je dis de la même façon que je
ne sone pas les reins et les cœurs et
les états d'âes des uns et des autres
mais que si on parine quelquen qui un
adversaire de notre candidat c'est la
même chose donc à chaque fois je fixe
des limites tout en
comprenant les interrogations les
réflexions parce que moi je ne suis pas
un
épurateur je suis un rassembleur et je
comprends qu'on puisse s'interroger mais
je dis à tout le monde il faut se
rassembler et ce soir donc dans un CER
que je viens de recevoir le sénateur
Parti socialiste ou pas vous allez nous
le dire François patria dit que vous
faites preuve d'aveux de faiblesse ça
c'est un argument vieux comme le monde
évidemment mais voilà je Seris très fort
si moi au Parti socialiste j'avais dit
et bien écoutez les gars vous soutenez
Emmanuel Macron bravo et c'est c'est
c'est enfin c'est un c'est un
raisonnement on va dire assez faible h
mais il y a beaucoup de douleur même
chez certaines personnes qui vont
pasiner Emmanuel Macron je pense au
député Christophe Castaner qui écrit que
ça lui coûte quand même he de tourner le
dos à son parti parce qu'il s'oriente
vers la gauche radicale et il oublie le
réel au nom d'un d'un faux idéal ça vous
pouvez l'entendre aussi c'est pour ça
que j'ai dit que c'est avec tristesse
puisque la plupart je le connais he
castag j'ai fait sa campagne pour les
élections régionales je me suis déplacé
plus d'une fois il a été très très
courageux d'ailleurs en retirant sa
liste aux élections régionales mais
voilà à un moment donné on fait des
choix alors le choix à mon avis on peut
on peut
critiquer la gauche du Parti socialiste
non non il critique le candidat et le
parti bien sûr bien sûr mais il il peut
critiquer le le candidat ou il peut
critiquer la gauche du Parti socialiste
c'est pas pour autant qu'il faut passer
autre part il était il faisait partie de
ceux qui était très sévère avec
lesffondeurs alors on peut pas renverser
tous les toutes les argumentations alors
vous dites que le Parti socialiste sera
indispensable après l'élection des
législatives mais écoutez ce que dit le
sénateur maire socialiste de Lyon Gérard
colon l'un des premiers à avoir suivi
Emmanuel Macron lui il le voit son
candidat porteur d'une nouvelle majorité
droite et
gauche ce que veulent les Français
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on sorte de cet
affrontement stérile entre gauche et
droite qui fait que quand la gauche est
au pouvoir la droite vote contre tous
les texte même s'il conviennent que
lorsque c'est le contraire on assiste au
phénomène inverse et cela fait
maintenant 20 ans que notre pays
n'avance pas et que nous régressons dans
le monde qu'est-ce que vous répondez
nelleité de choses il faudrait pas être
taquin avec mon ami Gérard Colomb Tib si
on n'est pas d'accord sur la
présidentielle reste un ami je n'ai pas
vu dans sa majorité municipale qu'il est
englobé la droite et la gauche il me
semble que il avait choisi la gauche et
hein et deuxièmement s'il pense
surmonter les blocages en faisant une
majorité qui va de
rebu à Madelin ouais
ça me semble tellement large qu'on va
finir par s'y perdre c'est une
caricature Madelin vient de
souteniraccord vient de soutenir est-ce
que Manuel Vals ne misait pas lui-même
sur une recomposition politique mais il
allait pas cherch Madelin quand mêmeuel
Val d'accord mais il parlait bien
progressistes de droite et la Gauche
moderne c'était un peu c'est un peu
l'idée là non qui est sur la table ah
non non non là là CIT C c'est non moi je
parle pas du projet de manuel
stratégique d'Emmanuel Macron il n'en a
pas parlé jusqu'à présent je parle de ce
que nous disait l'ami colon il il a
décrit un paysage où en fin de compte le
centre s'élargirait au centre gauche et
au centre droit mais il s'est tellement
élargi qu'on est pas au centre gauche et
au centre- droit on est à rebu à à
Madelin enfin je sais pas comment vous
allez faire une synthèse entre les deux
moi qui dois faire la synthèse au Parti
socialiste je vous avoue que l'écart est
quand même moins grand si on entend bien
tout ce que vous dites depuis au début
vous rejetez totalement une idée de
contrat de gouvernance avec Emmanuel
Macron aujourd'hui non mais aujourd'hui
je suis dans le le combat pour mon
candidatd' aujourd'hui je suis dans le
combat pour que notre candidat l'emporte
si s'il l'emportait je pense qu'il
ferait un contrat de gouvernement et on
verrait qui le suivit si d'autres
l'emportent si c'est la droite je n'en
serai pas si c'est l'extrême droite je
la combattrai et si c'est Emmanuel
Macron nous verrons ce qui se passera
c'est pas moi qui déciderai vous ne
rejetez pas une attendue éventuelle mais
elle ne sera pas tendue vous avez bien
entendu ce qu'il a dit il présentera 577
candidats non 577 circonscription ça
veut dire qu'il y a pas de mainentendu
ça veut dire qu'il y a une y a une
confrontation avec le Parti socialiste
il y a pas de geste visant à dire que
bon bah on verra si je gagne à
réunir le centre gauche avec la gauche
il ne peut pas le faire pourquoi parce
qu'il a besoin de la droite pour pouvoir
continuer son
chemin voilà
on verra moi je suis je ne suis pas dans
la situation je ne suis pas dans la
situation de l'après présidentielle avec
Macron élu Président je suis dans la
situation d'un combat pour essayer
d'obtenir que notre candidat puisse
l'emporter à titre un peu plus personnel
il y aura forcément un congrès après
l'élection présidentielle au Parti
socialiste est-ce que vous pouvez dire
aujourd'hui que quoi qu'il arrive vous
serez candidat au renouvellement de
votre poste écoutez je vous donne
rendez-vous le 18 juin non pas pour
lancer un appel mais pour euh discuter
de cette importante question et nous
verrons à ce moment-là s'il y a un
congrès dans quelle situation nous
serons à quelle date il aura lieu et si
moi je serai candidat ou pas Emmanuel
Macron est se fait fort d'avoir de
nouveaux riments de droite il en a déjà
enregistré on parle de prise de guerre à
Paris notamment avec certains élus au
Conseil de Paris de droite he pas
seulement des socialistes proches d'algo
qui se tourne vers lui est-ce que ça ça
vous gêne ça vous choque cette volonté
d'aller draguer à droite mais il a
décidé de faire une campagne plus de
centre- droit que de centregauche parce
que il a vu les difficultés de Monsieur
Fillon et il s'est dit qu'il y avait une
possibilité de ramener à lui un certain
nombre d'électeurs c'est moi j'ai
toujours dit la chose suivante c'est que
quand Emmanuel Macron est sorti du
gouvernement il pouvait être intéressant
pour les socialistes il pouvait sembler
intéressant pour des socialistes ou des
hommes et des femmes de gauche euh et
donc à ce moment-là je comprenais que
des camarades moi comme colon soit
intéressé par cette démarche mais à
partir du moment où il passe au centre-
droit où il dit qu'il va supprimer
125000 fonctionnaires où il fait les
déclarations qu'encore ce matin sur le
compte pénibilité négocié par entreprise
euh je vois je me dis c'est peut-être
pas le moment d'aller vers lui donc je
je vois pas euh si Emmanuel Macron est
élu président de la République hypothèse
est-ce que vous estimerez que la gauche
resterit au pouvoir bah c'est parce
qu'il estimera vous avez entendu il
estimera que c'est un dépassement de la
gauche par la gauche et la droite
dernière question peut-être au lendemain
de du classement sans suite de l'enquête
contre Denis beupin pour agression
sexuelle il annonce porter plainte
contre ses accusatrice et contre son
parti qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire je
crois qu'il veut se défendre mais bon
moi je n'ai pas à commenter là des
décisions de justice qui se portent sur
une personne je n'ai pas de commentaire
j'ai pas de commentaire à faire c'est
utile pour lui de porter plainte alors
qu'il y avait un soupçon de harcèlement
sexuel avec des témoignages très forts
dans la presse vous vous souvenez oui
oui mais je je ne suis pas son conseil
et si son conseil lui a proposé de
porter plainte c'est qu'il en avait les
moyens je suppose quand est-ce qu'on
vous retrouve à côté de Benoît amamont
pour faire campagne sur le terrain mais
moi je suis tout le temps je suis tout
le temps tous les jours je parle au
candidats j'essaie de d'essayer à ma
place de faire en sorte que tout le
monde soit dans la la campagne ou tout
du moins pas trop éloigné bon et vous
sauverez la maison PS ah j'y compte bien
oui diselle est proche de la ruine oui
mais on dit ça tout le temps on dit ça
on dit ça tout le temps et puis on
regardait ce qu'on disait avant la
primaire puis après on a vu qu'on
faisait quand même 2 millions de votants
hein c'est quand même non négligeable et
je crois que tous les socialistes
peuvent avoir des états d'âes sur la
présidentielle mais ils sont tous
attachés au Parti socialiste merci à
vous merci michaell on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine et notre invité sera
Gérard Larcher le président du Sénat qui
est donc derrière François
[Musique]
Fillon pour moi ça serait la gratuité
des transports publics politique des
transports et en particulier le rôle de
la SNCF est à revoir parce que c'est pas
non plus le car qui va résoudre des
problèmes
[Musique]
d'environnement vos rendez-vous avec
Public
Sénat présidentielle 201 quel rôle et
quels moyen pour les départements et la
décentralisation l'Assemblée des
départements de France interroge les
candidats à l'Élysée un événement à
suivre en direct sur les chaînes
parlementaires demain à
9h je suis une femme et j'ose me
présenter première femme à se présenter
à la candidature suprême comme on dit
oui il fallait oser le faire et je l'ai
fait d'ailleurs en m'adressant à toutes
les femmes pas seul celle de la classe
ouvrière qu'est-ce qu'elle a ma
gueule qu'on puisse me faire un
traitement particulier parce que je suis
une femme c'est une injure c'est une
infamie pour moi mes collègues étaient
absolument fascinés étaient tout
émoustillé personne n'aurait imaginé de
dire le général de Gaulle se quasich
chauve j'en fais aujourd'hui av une
manière de parler que les femmes ont
souvent en politique qui est pas la même
il y avait le côté mère protectrice on a
beaucoup de mal à considérer qu'une
femme qui entre en politique fait de son
propre chef d'un côté il prétend d'être
heureux de voir des femmes se présenter
à la présidence de la République de
l'autre côté ils sont pas forcément
prêts à voter pour elle un jour je serai
présidente demain à 17h sur Public
[Musique]
Sénat on va plus loin c'est votre
rendez-vous en direct avec l'information
Sonia mabrook reçoit pendant 90 minutes
en débat et en entretien ceux qui font
l'actualité on va même aller plus loin
la majorité des Américains sont pour ce
décret la cause principale de cette
Europe qui va très mal c'est une France
qui va très très mal on sa que les
civilisations naissent vivent meurent
disparaissent et je vois pas pourquoi la
nôre échapperait à ce chez malade on va
plus loin du lundi au jeudi à 22h en
direct sur public
sat Public Sénat au cœur du
débat